[Music]
and what the [ __ ] news
and what the [ __ ] do you think you're
doing submitted by
stephanie says hi jk
you hold a napkin in between your fists
like that you can punch better [ __ ] you
hi somebody
you know i gotta say whenever i read the
titles i like i always like to surprise
myself like sometimes i'll read the
first two words and i'm like
don't read anymore just wait i get so
excited okay
a man was shocked to discover
girlfriend's secret bathroom habit
involving his socks she likes to
smell oh yeah that's the only thing i
can picture while sitting on the toilet
taking his [ __ ]
she wipes her ass with his socks i'm
trying to think of like what's the
weirdest thing you can do stuff sit in
her mouth
and then jack's off she jacks one of the
nastiest things on earth
well used socks yeah they're pretty
yucky or thongs
those are pretty gross with skid marks
on well i'm just thinking because you
just sweat
it is impressive to get a skid mark on a
thong it is
i was like a skid mark on a sock or a
thong like i'm like all right
guess doesn't have skid marks on a thong
but one of my exes did wow
we were in bed and i looked at her
underwear and i'm like well she was
wearing it
no no it was on the floor and it was a
skid mark and i said you want to throw
that away
and she's like no and i'm like oh my god
and that's when it started
or a period yeah it could be a period
they look like dookie to me
but period dry period blood and dookie
look the exact
one's a streak and one's a little puddle
but if it's in a thong
but okay i'm sorry because like that's
why i'm trying to process this i'm like
i'm an open person i understand
everyone's got like you know body things
like that
and i'm like i don't think i've ever
gone through a period where i'm like wow
that's skid mark like you know like
what's going on don't you just
don't you just wipe your butt maybe she
wasn't thorough with it
yeah did you ever go down there to check
no that's when our relationship started
dwindling because
i was like how dare you put that back on
i mean like
i would have just rinsed it washed it or
threw it away and went commando back on
what oh my gosh
and that's when the relationship started
to dwindle sam all right
well let me tell you about this lady
does it make sense if we were in high
school because she was young so she did
stupid things
no dude if you or anyone you know find
skid marks call the police
i'm pretty [ __ ] gross i'm pretty
[ __ ] gross right and i wouldn't even
do that dude
if my own underwear had skid marks i
would [ __ ] burn it or throw it away
think about damier guy like can y'all
please think about dating a dude and he
had skid marks in his boxers like i
would forgive that though because dudes
are disgusting dudes are more just
discussing girls yeah but wouldn't it
make more sense to have skin marks on a
thong than a boxer because the skin mark
does make sense
rides up that ass and if you don't wash
thoroughly or like there's times when
you do wipe but then there's just that
extra lump that just skid marks along
and it gets flossed away you know what i
mean it gets flossed then it would
saturate the whole back into the pan
cleaner it's almost like imagine you're
dating this chick and her bo is stronger
than yours
damn that's me that's me right now
my bio is way stronger he has no bo i
have just regular bo
oh [ __ ] what am i doing here a lot of a
lot of asian dudes don't have bo though
we got steak breath not bo i don't wear
deodorant either what
i only wear deodorant because it was
taught to me that i should yeah yeah but
most of the times i don't know i have to
because i'm like oh my god i didn't wear
deodorant and i start panicking and i'm
like oh boss do you have some please
someone
i'll get b.o if like i'm working out for
a very very long period of time i play
basketball and it's during the
same it takes a long time but if i'm
just chilling like this or if i just do
an hour workout i won't get beat up but
my head smells like [ __ ] all the time
and his breath
yeah rbo comes out of our breath in our
head and our fart you don't wear
deodorant either you don't have b.o
sometimes what
i get like do you do the same for casey
it's a shower every
exactly because i think that's his thing
because i've traveled with him and
there's times i'm like
he wore that like three times in a row
he showered in like three days
so that might be it if he showered every
day i don't think you'd have b.o
i've seen casey sleep in his clothes
multiple times so have i
dude i get like i'm married too
anxious if i forget to put on deodorant
like do you all ever have a time where
like you feel a tingle in your body and
then you just start sweating
like i'll like hit the break and like
i'll be like oh [ __ ] i forgot deodorant
and then i just start pouring sweat
or it just feels it feels sticky to me
oh yeah i can like
feel the sweat and i'm just like oh i'll
smell like
moist sweat but not that bo smell no i
have that onion
[ __ ] oh damn you don't smell like b.o
i don't oh i don't i don't think i do
either i just really
no i smell you've never smelled like
that though because you always you're
always careful about it
julie is enough [ __ ] back there what
happened julia
uh i dropped my phone but fun fact
though people who have get in the
[ __ ]
get over here all right so recently
i read up that people that have the wet
type of ear wax they actually have the
bo so agent oh i love the wow
yeah asians only the ones i know always
have dry you look like coraline
with the yellow do you have wet or dry
ear wax i have wet so i you got stinky
[Applause]
i never smelled you yeah you shouldn't
um i'm sorry i have
waxy ear wax no there's wet and there's
dry so
that you're waxy i guess you're wet yeah
you're wet girl yeah yours is wet
because it's yours ever just like
flaky yeah is it flaky and turns powdery
right it's like
waxy yeah oh that's wet sweat me too i
have the waxy one
okay so you guys have like ears it's
like dandruff coming out of the ear for
them to clean the ears they use like the
scoopy thing
got it cause sometimes i'm just sitting
there and i could just feel
like it just like come off yeah yeah i'm
just like a snowflake just
[Laughter]
all right so let me tell you about this
girl oh yeah wait who are we talking
about
let's talk about [ __ ] nasty body [ __ ]
it was just funny that bart's like just
imagine your girl having more beer than
you
like uh right here bro it's us that's
because i never smell it that's why
oh that's nice that's good to know i did
when i was doing it with this girl
and she was like oh i thought when when
i was on top of her i put her hands down
like this
she was like oh my god like that and
then i had to put it down like do it all
sexy that's think that stink
she's like handcuffed me to the post
can't do it no no no no no
i i got my hand cut your own ankles
both armpits oh boy smelled like a
stinky feet this was posted on reddit
under subreddit relationship advice and
the title
says i 28 think my girlfriend 26 has
been using my gym
socks to wipe after going to the
bathroom i told you
what kind
so he started realizing that a lot of
his songs have been disappointing
so first of all they've been together
for a few months that's it and then they
recently moved into together red flag
bro they do share a lot of the household
responsibilities but the one thing that
she
has been adamant about is doing the
laundry and so he just thought like oh
that's really sweet you know like she
wants to take care of my clothes
whatever
but then he ends up finding in the
hamper
dookie sucks a dookie sock cocka socks
oh
he was like what the [ __ ] that's nasty
we don't have any pets we don't have any
kids
who's wiping whose poop is on my socks
why is there [ __ ] on my front of her
about it she's salvador and huh
and then she what salvador she's
cheating do a fecal test whose poop is
this
i'm serious so then she ends up breaking
down
and crying and saying that fresh socks
or dirty socks that's a good question
because you said gym socks right
hopefully it's fresh you should use gym
socks enough i don't know if it was used
you just said it's just his gym socks so
it might be workout socks
yeah i could kind of get it if it's
fresh because so it's like using cloth
you know
it's like you're [ __ ] you're a baller
then you should buy a [ __ ] towel
yeah or use your own socks maybe she
likes this
i don't know the smell of him sorry i'm
just gonna put on conspiracy bows for a
second
just hear me out y'all so let's say that
she says yeah i'm sorry it was me i was
wiping my ass with your socks you know
but she was actually cheating and it was
the dude wiping his ass with his socks
as a power move
because he's like [ __ ] you i'm [ __ ]
your girl and he would like you know
like that's more rational than her being
like oh and then of course for her it's
easier to be like
i'm pooping on your socks babe please
forgive me rather than i stuck this
dude's dick and he hates you so
i think you're right how long is it skid
mark because if it's guy ass
it's a big one but if it's a girl ass
might be like so let me clarify
something he didn't find
the poop socks in the laundry hamper i
messed up
she threw it away so he found it in a
trash can
keeps missing socks she's courteous and
throws it away
yeah then why is she doing the laundry
[ __ ] disappears in the laundry
yeah so there were so inside of a bag
there were several
pairs of his gym socks covered and she's
stupid
i think he would know that his socks are
gone yeah what's she thinking
yeah so then anyway so she breaks down
she says like oh you know i just i
can't use toilet paper i like using
socks to wipe
because it covers my hand completely
funny why don't you use her own socks
she does usually use but she ran out of
her own socks she used her own socks
get some kitchen gloves get a little
sticky thing with a chain
keep them on the sink just get your
toilet paper and then you just
get a bidet that's what a lot of people
have been commenting on this post
saying like you know either get up a day
take her to a therapist
and then maybe do um some exposure
therapy so like
use the sock but then put toilet paper
on it oh i thought
right like you have to buy pairs and
pairs of socks just to [ __ ] take a
[ __ ] she could have bought a new house
she has a fear of getting poop on her
hands so this is three months in would
you all ride it out or would you break
up with her
guys are dumb they're going to be like
haha she exactly
let's say she's a seven what i mean okay
well she's
using a sock to wash like wipe your ass
it's not as bad as eating [ __ ] and also
is she
guy logic is she still using the toilet
paper with the sock as a glove
because if so now this is just stupid
because yeah the the sock has got to be
some kind of fetish or something
and it's going to permeate yes that's
what i was thinking it probably has
holes in it yeah and it's not really
thick at least with the toilet paper you
can wrap it as much as you want
yeah and if she's still using the toilet
paper in the hand with the socks then
just get a [ __ ] glove
yeah yeah maybe this feels great i'm
gonna try it ew
i've tried it before same here what oh
bart
you guys are meant to be together well i
tried it because this was panic mode
you didn't have you didn't have toilet
paper public it was a public restroom
but it was the
it was like the stall it's not even just
one room
and it was huge it was long and i don't
know where everyone else was and i'm
like oh
i could be by myself too and i looked
there's no toilet paper and i remember
his story of him grabbing used toilet
paper from
taiwanese and i was like taiwanese
no mark quan style so then i looked at
everything that i had right
bring down a whole culture with you dude
so then i was like well what's gotta go
is it gonna be my shirt is it gonna be
my underwear it's gonna be my socks i'm
like well i got two socks if i don't
wipe
right the first time you got another one
there you go so i'm like well [ __ ] it's
not gonna ruin my outfit i can still
walk around with those socks so the
socks had to go and it wasn't anything
special
no but did it turn you on no no then
you're good
did it feel different than toilet paper
it did it was luxurious
but yeah it wasn't anything different
i've done socks my underwear
leaves napkins paper
all right [ __ ] bubba gum shrimp
company
napkins construction paper construction
paper wool socks summertimes
t-shirts wife feeders wife
beaters gloves cardboard
sawdust rocks wonder bread
navigation course when i was in the
military and then like it's like a
eight-hour long course so in the course
of eight hours if you've been
shoving mres down your throat for like
the whole week
your poop is like couldn't come out at
any time solid and then so sometimes
there's no you're on the out in the
middle of nowhere
so sometimes you got a [ __ ] random
newspaper a map
maybe perhaps we never used your hand
hell no i don't what am i gonna wash it
with why are you so offended with me
what the [ __ ]
my hand has to go back on my trigger you
know what i just i'm not gonna have [ __ ]
on my [ __ ]
gun but you pick up dog [ __ ] that's at
home loaded that's a
what it's a hole at home i can wash my
hands when i'm out over there
i have to use my hands to eat later pick
my nose pull the trigger
still do things so i use everything else
[Music]